hi this is a very important video I hope
you watch it to the end it's about what
happens when you take a guy with a very
fragile ego and you know what they say
about guys with fragile egos and you go
ahead and you talk about how they
systematically copied and ripped off
other people's content what do they do
they copyright strike your video now why
have I not mentioned copycat Kevin's
name yet and I'm not going to say his
full name so we don't even know who I
would be in theory talking about it's
because copycat Kevin becomes copyright
Kevin when you talk about him and one of
the reasons for it is that he says his
name is copyrighted which by the way
isn't even a thing it's not a thing it's
not a thing
so the merits of his copyright takedown
are just wrong from the outset but I
don't have that that all the videos that
we used were in fair use I was comparing
what he says to what some another guru
says right before him because he copies
other gurus content right
this was the whole video is what the
whole video is about but he takes it
down why because number one he wants to
silence this right he wants to silence
this story he knew the video was going
viral and he knows by by putting his
thumb on it for 21 days or however long
he can he can hold it down he can
suppress the video right he could
suppress the video he can keep it quiet
the problem with that plan is that now
we're talking now we're really getting
into but the second reason is that
there's nothing to refute in my video I
mean look the way you normally handle
this if you were criticized by a channel
with 20,000 subscribers how you do it
when you have a 700,000 subscriber
audience is you make a video saying hey
this video is wrong for XYZ reasons he
doesn't do that and he doesn't refute me
because there's nothing to refute it's
all it's true it's just true and if
that's my opinion
just come on the show Kevin don't don't
copyright claim me because I used your
name don't go from copycat Kevin to
copyright Kevin you know just just come
on the show you can come off the show I
let all the Guru's on my show if they
have the balls to do it but that's not
what you did Kevin that's not what you
did instead you went and you falsely
took down my video under weak pretenses
like your name is copyrighted having to
first
here watch I'll say to first names and
they have no relation to each other
Kevin and David having that is a full
name isn't copyrightable are we in
fairytale land
I mean dude honestly what clown world
are we in that this would be a thing you
can't talk about me because if you say
my name then I'm gonna I'm gonna
copyright strike you what what are you
saying that he is this ultimately it's
not about him having a realistic claim
it's about him silencing criticism and
hoping it goes away
now the next step for Kevin I'll tell
you the normal plan for a lot of these
fake gurus who want to evade criticism
is to send a cease and desist letter to
me which I will promptly throw in the
trash and then he can subpoena me and I
have liability insurance and I will
continue talking about you Kevin I'll
talk about you all day
the more that you try to put your thumb
on me the more you try to silence me the
more I'll talk about you buddy by the
way this just proves my claim that you
are the worst fake guru no other fake
guru has copyright claim to my video no
other fake guru has tried to say their
name is copyrighted or that oh because
you clearly used my video in fair use
I'm gonna copyright strike your channel
no other guru has done this because no
other guru frankly has as much to hide
this is an embarrassing abuse of the
copyright law and it needs to stop so
what I want from you guys the reason I'm
making this public it's because Kevin
wants to silence the story clearly and
anytime someone wants to hide the truth
it becomes that much more important to
tell so what I want from you guys is
please share this video I made a Twitter
thread summarizing actually what my
original video was sort of about which
was about how he systematically copies
other gurus content and a lot of his
stuff isn't original that is below you
can go ahead and share that Twitter
thread and then also go to Instagram put
a like on that you can follow me if you
want don't follow me if you don't want
the point is not to get followers the
point is not to get money this video
isn't monetized
the point is to bring attention to the
problem of how these fake gurus silence
criticism they silenced criticism
through all these back a lead ways of
using their money to try to put their
thumb on somebody but it's not gonna
work guys the fake guru army isn't gonna
let that
work please share this video Kevin
you're just making things worse
release the claim let's stop doing this
dance trust me you want to be known as
copycat Kevin you don't want to be known
as copyright Kevin as always you can
come to your own conclusions this isn't
just my opinion I am just presenting the
evidence I have to you you can let me
know what you think in the comments
below thank you for watching I will talk
to you guys later